[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
many employers around the country are
grappling with how to get workers back
safely in this pandemic
epic systems is a healthcare software
company that is the largest private
sector employer in dane county wisconsin
well now it faces objections from
hundreds of employees
to its plans to put thousands of workers
back together on its office campus
our consumer investigative correspondent
anna warner along with our partners at
clear health costs
have been learning why some employees
are so upset
well some major tech companies are
keeping their employees working from
home
google through next july twitter
indefinitely
but this giant medical records software
company says all of its employees needed
to come back to the office
and now some of those employees are
speaking to us
nearly 10 thousand people work at epic's
medical records software business on
this sprawling campus outside madison
in mid-march most shifted to working
from home
but now the company says they must come
back
chief administrative officer svarawan we
know that we have this responsibility to
health care workers around the world
and to their patients to make sure that
we are at our very best
the fact is that we can't do what we do
without being together at the absolute
highest level
rawang says to enhance safety on epic's
unique
theme park like campus visited by cbs
late last year
the company took extra steps including
private offices for its employees
enhanced heating and filtration systems
and a take-out only cafeteria
we are not taking this lightly and so we
will do so in a very
mindful and careful way and make sure
that it's safe
but some employees say they don't feel
safe and worry about spreading infection
we've concealed these two employees
identities because they fear being fired
i am deeply morally outraged by
our response i feel like we are not
evaluating the risk that we are taking
i don't want us to be the epicenter of
the next breakout they're reacting to an
email sent to staff earlier this month
by epic ceo judy faulkner obtained by
cbs news
in it she told employees staff working
at home is not nearly as good as staff
working at epic
even if work gets done we are losing big
time the culture that made the company
successful
executives say even workers with high
risk health conditions must return to
the office by november
i have to make the hard choice between
do i risk getting sick or do i risk not
having a paycheck
in internal employee surveys obtained by
cbs news
hundreds of staffers voiced their
objections one writing
i'm quite frankly embarrassed to work at
a company that values employee and
public safety so little
and from another this there will be
people who die
because of epic's insistence on
returning to campus
they described it as dangerous rushed
unnecessary shameful disappointing
wildly irresponsible and a disaster
if the company is doing as good of a job
prioritizing safety with this plan as
you say you
are why are the employees describing it
in that fashion
well i i haven't seen those uh
expressions uh and i hope and
that all of our employees can continue
to work with us
to make sure that we are doing the very
best
by them did you personally read the
surveys
i did and you don't remember these
comments
they we like i said we have a number of
channels that we have
where we get comments uh from employees
including uh
in an email group um all i
was meaning to say is that i don't
recall those words from that survey
but we certainly are hearing the
concerns of our staff just because you
can go back into the office doesn't mean
that you should go back into the office
dr ann ramoin is a ucla professor of
epidemiology
to forfeit safety for the idea of having
collaborative moments is
is something that i just can't agree
with
employees who now have no choice but to
return say they just hope the company
will reconsider
please put the safety of your employees
and the greater community
first now since we spoke with them in an
email to employees late last night
epic ceo said the company is now having
nationally recognized experts review its
plans
and will make adjustments as needed she
also revealed that since the start of
the pandemic
24 staff have tested positive but said
that none of them
said the source came from epic the first
wave of
workers is expected back on monday
yeah it's a tough choice you heard that
employee say having to choose
between getting sick or receiving a
paycheck
our thanks to anna warner for that
reporting